the interesting question to me is is
something like schizophrenia this
disease this mental illness now that we
know so well now is it more like
breaking a bone in a sense that when the
brain breaks it breaks in a very
stereotypes in specific way it's like
the physical properties of the brain
that when they break they break the same
way or is it something more like cancer
where it's kind of the environmental
conditions don't quite they weren't
quite there they had it but there wasn't
the the there was a propensity but it
just kind of never came out and so
people have thought about this in terms
of the history of schizophrenia that's
the thing I'm most interested in part of
a part of why I studied this parasite is
it's one of the most tractable ways of
studying a schizophrenia disease model
and so when people are thinking about
this history of this of this illness you
can ask something like well when was the
first diagnosis and the first diagnosis
was in the 1880s and people have thought
you know what actually what would
happened was sometime that was the
century when people first started living
in cities and if you if you remember
from the slide about the risk factors
for schizophrenia number one is being an
immigrant immigrants often go to cities
number two is being raised in an urban
environment
number four is being born there sorry is
living in an urban environment so
there's a link somewhere between cities
in schizophrenia and so people have
thought well maybe maybe this explains
why nobody was schizophrenic before
there were cities that had more than a
million people so these are all the
cities that had more than million - more
than a million people in their
population but London Shanghai and 1800
were the first to sustain that so I want
to go somewhere different though and I
want to talk about well what can we do
what can we ask about this history of
this mental illness in terms of art so
there's this man Louis Wayne he was a
turn-of-the-century artist turn of 19th
century so late 18-hundreds early 1900s
and he used to draw our cats and he even
seemed so famous that he had like a
Louis Wayne cat was a thing that people
new people knew have the lewis wayne cat
you could buy postcards and so he was
the president of national cat society he
drew his still lifes from the cats that
he owned and he would live with up to 40
and he went schizophrenic and so there's
something really neat about an artist I
mean sorry no I entirely take that back
so we saw his art and we have his art
and we can see his art change as he
develops his mentalness so I'll just let
the art talk so there's something a
little weird that the cat on your left
the one with the green eyes he's like a
little suspicious he's not a cat that's
like everything's okay so here we have I
love the title of this actually this
fire the mind agitates the atmosphere
it's the title of this piece and then it
starts to get a little otter the blur
the blurred lines between self and
non-self in inside subjective world
outside worlds you know it starts to
blur a little bit he starts to get a
little more fractal kind of odd maybe a
little bit otter and so this is the
point I think where if you're his friend
and he used to do this and now he's
doing this you're just like do you want
to go for a tea see what I like talk and
so it continues and it deteriorates and
it gets it gets really really abstract
and so there's this idea of can we take
something like art can we take something
like art as a narrative can we take a
sequence of things that people have
drawn and produced and actually think
about it in the same way that we use to
think about diagnosing mental illness
and the only reason I say that is
because if you go into a hospital now
and you you are diagnosed with
schizophrenia not with a blood test or a
brain scan
there's no EMR it's a behavioral
checklist and the question is can we use
art to go back in time and analyze and
say maybe schizophrenic drew a certain
type of art let's say could we then go
back in the history of arts and find all
the schizophrenic sand then say okay yes
there was schizophrenia that's a very
like first pass crude version of this
[Music]